votre juron gros mots blast un favori ah
ça vous allez chercher et [ __ ] de
merde
[Musique]
à votre mot préféré alain delon honneur
le mot vous détestez et virtuels votre
drogue favorite
l'amour le son le bruit que vous aimez
le bruit du loup le hurlement du loup la
nuit dans la forêt ah bon c'est alors le
son le bruit que vous détestez le bruit
des fusils qui tirent les loups et tous
les autres animaux votre juron gros mots
blast un favori ah ça vous allez
chercher real et [ __ ] de merde [ __ ]
de merde c'est bien français eh ben
voilà c'est très bien mais je suis bien
français croyez moi un mou femmes pour
illustrer un nouveau billet de banque
je dirais charles de gaulle ou brigitte
bardot et pourquoi pas les deux ensemble
bien sincèrement le métier vous n'auriez
pas aimé faire maître nageur ici j'ai
horreur de nos et puis je me serais très
vite en lui et j'aurai pas la patience
la plante la roue l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être rijkaard alors tout
de suite un malinois c'est un berger
belge suivie dans mon enfance une
maligne au point et si dieu existe qu
aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire avoue alain delon
alors je vais vous le dire puisque tel
est ton plus grand étant plus profonds
regrets je le sais viens je te mène à
ton père et ta mère afin que pour la
première fois
enfin tu les vois ensemble
[Musique]